[Música]
3 de marzo de 2016 estamos
estefanía yo hay paradas en frente de la
piscina con dos paneles de jueces al
lado con siete jueces más o menos cada
uno
acabamos de nadar el dúo técnico estamos
super cansadas nuestras piernas no nos
logran sostener en pie los brazos nos
duelen como si hubiéramos acabado por
una acabo de pasar por una máquina de
moler pero acabamos de nadar es el dúo
técnico y sabemos que lo hicimos muy
bien porque en la esquina de la piscina
estan paula y marga nuestras
entrenadoras con una sonrisa de oreja a
oreja y tan ansiosas como nosotros por
recibir esas calificaciones y esas
puntuaciones en la pantalla del frente
en este momento están pasando nuestra
rutina en cámara lenta y lo que estamos
esperando es que salga el ranking y la
puntuación supremamente ansiosas
esperando esperando eso y entonces
ahorita les cuento qué pasó
muchos jóvenes no tienen la oportunidad
de conocer y de saber para que tienen
talento
si es para el arte si es para el baile
si es para la academia si es para cantar
si es para un montón de cosas para que
para las que los niños pueden tener
talento pero hay otros jóvenes
y en los que yo me incluyo que supimos
desde muy pequeños para qué servía mos y
para que teníamos capacidades el nado
sincronizado que es ahora la natación
artística le cambiaron el nombre desde
el año pasado es un deporte en el que
los procesos inician desde muy pequeñas
yo a los cuatro años y medio de edad
inicia el proceso en el shofar que era
un centro que nos preparaba para el alto
rendimiento y era era un centro en el
que los niños que estábamos ahí teníamos
la oportunidad de practicar todas las
modalidades de los deportes acuáticos
que son polo acuático nado sincronizado
clavados y natación carreras al final
del proceso nos decían para qué deporte
servíamos y nos daban a elegir casi
siempre entre dos deportes mis deportes
fueron clavados y nado sincronizado en
este momento yo no sé por qué elegí nado
sincronizado porque soy fan número uno
de los clavados pero es gracias a eso a
esa decisión que tomé estando tan
chiquita que estoy aquí en este momento
completamente enamorada mi deporte y
hablándoles a ustedes
cuáles son las capacidades que miraban
para saber si uno podría ser bueno o no
para el nuevo sincronizando son muy
claras las capacidades físicas y están
súper influidas por las rusas que son
las nadadoras que dominan el deporte y
que ellas están hechas para el deporte
lo ideal es tener las caderas más
angostas que la espalda tener cuello
largo y delgado tener las piernas largas
rectas en lo posible proporcionales es
decir que esta medida sea igual a la
medida de abajo tener los tobillos y las
rodillas delgadas y tener glúteos no
prominentes
esa era mi mejor cualidad
esas eran las características físicas
pero había mucho muchas niñas que
cumplían en las características muchas
niñas que tenían todos esos parámetros
cumplidos y que fue lo que nos hizo
diferentes en ese momento en el que yo
estaba ahí chiquita en mi graduación del
cefar que era un evento completamente
grande para ser nosotras tan chiquitas
yo no sabía en ese punto
cuán importantes iban a ser para mí las
capacidades mentales las capacidades
psicológicas pero son esas las que nos
hicieron diferentes es la mente la que
nos hizo ser capaces de creer que
podíamos lograr un sueño de toda una
vida y un sueño de todo un país quiera
lograr la clasificación a los juegos
olímpicos por primera vez por colombia
nado sincronizado y abriéndole así el
camino un montón de chiquitas que vienen
trabajando con nosotras como referente y
que quieren lograr muchas más cosas que
nosotras
cuando tenía más o menos 10 años
recuerdo que mi amo me estaba peinando y
me estaba haciendo pues la momia y me
estaba estirando el pelo a tal punto en
el que tenía los ojos super chinos y yo
decía dios mío si voy a poder ver a mis
compañeras en la rutina ahí les muestro
que no es mentira
realmente costaba ver en una no estoy
como muy contento en ese punto en el que
no me está peinando yo tuve un
pensamiento en voz alta y dije yo quiero
ir a unos juegos olímpicos en ese punto
me dijeron mis compañeras estas locas
eso no se va a lograr colombiano tiene
la posición política para hacerlo
colombia no ha ido nunca es imposible
nosotros somos de suramérica bueno un
montón de cosas alrededor y mi mamá lo
único que puedo decirles fue déjenla
soñar
tal vez lo pueda lograr o tal vez pueda
trabajar para ello eso es un diálogo que
tengo muy en mente porque es un diálogo
que se ha repetido durante toda mi
carrera deportiva hasta lo que soy hoy
tengo 25 años llevo 21 años en este
deporte eso es casi toda una vida mi
infancia mi adolescencia mi primer novio
mis amigos los momentos más tristes de
mayor aprendizaje así como también los
momentos más felices los pases en una
piscina pero no solamente en mi vida
estaba alrededor de una piscina también
la vida de mi familia
yo vengo de una familia en la que somos
tres hijas las tres hijas somos
deportistas las tres somos selección
colombia y tenemos unos papás que nos
enseñaron desde muy pequeñas a ser muy
disciplinadas
pero sobre todo nos enseñaron a soñar ya
que teníamos que trabajar por esos
sueños y los queríamos cumplir nos
enseñaron esa disciplina y esa capacidad
de lucha por esos sueños yo puedo decir
que no recuerdo ningún momento en el que
mis papás me hayan dicho no te vamos a
llevar a un entrenamiento ni siquiera
los entrenamientos de las cuatro a la
mañana que yo decía dios mío que no
suene la alarma que pase algo no sé que
caiga un meteorito que haya una tormenta
que pase algo para que yo no me tenga
que meter a esa piscina a las cuatro de
la mañana con ese frío siendo chiquita
pero ahí estaban mis papás mostrándome
que era la decisión que yo había tomado
estar ahí y dándome ejemplo de
disciplina y de constancia hacían un
montón de actividades para que yo
pudiera ir a mis viajes o pudiera cubrir
mis gastos y que pudiera seguir
disfrutando de lo que el que más me
gustaba me quiera estar en una piscina
al ser un deporte poco reconocido el
nado sincronizado es un deporte en el
que no hay mucho apoyo económico
entonces nosotros nos convertimos en de
toreras somos maquilladoras peluqueras
managers organizadoras de viajes
diseñadores de vestuario hasta djs para
hacer la edición de la música mejor yo
pregunté por lo que no vea porque
realmente lo hacemos todo pero es la
posición de cada quien la posición que
cada quien elija si quiere ver eso como
un lastre o como un trampolín y nosotros
elegimos ver eso como un trampolín
yo podría estar aquí hablándoles de
cuántos sacrificios hice por mi deporte
podría estar acá diciéndoles cuántas
clases tuve que aplazar cuantas materias
tuve que cancelar a cuántos compañeros
de la universidad me tocó ver que se
graduaban y yo todavía estaba estudiando
a cuántos paseos familiares falte pero
yo pienso que esa palabra sacrificio no
es la palabra que es más vinculada a mi
historia porque el sacrificio implica
sufrimiento y sacrificio implica un
anhelo por hacer algo que no se hizo
e implica una tristeza por no hacer esas
cosas que la persona quiere hacer por
eso pienso que todo eso se junta y se
vuelve en un enemigo completo del
disfrute entonces pienso que la palabra
que más se vincula
a mi historia es la palabra esfuerzo
porque cada entrenamiento cada minuto de
tiempo que yo le quite a mi vida social
cada minuto que yo le quite a todo lo
que lo que hacía yo en otros ámbitos
para dedicarle entrenamiento a cada
entrenamiento fue un
un granito de arena para cumplir ese
sueño tan grande que hemos tenido
nosotras
quiero comentarles que para nosotros ha
sido supremamente importante esas
capacidades psicológicas porque son
ellas las que se convirtieron en nuestra
mejor herramienta para luchar un montón
de batallas batallas con los jueces
batallas con la política batallas con
los apoyos con los patrocinadores pero
no solamente teníamos ese montón de
batallas teníamos también un montón de
aliados entidades que nos patrocinaron
entidades que nos pagaron los viajes
porque nado sincronizado es supremamente
importante que los jueces te vean que
los jueces te reconozcan y te vayan
dando una mejor calificación cada vez
entrenadores de afuera que vinieron a
ayudarnos a modificar nuestras rutinas
de entrenamiento que nos ayudaron a
modificar también las coreografías para
que fueran mucho más internacionales y
la familia que evidentemente estaba ahí
junto con toda una comunidad del deporte
que estaba siempre pendiente de que
tuviéramos buenos resultados con esto
quiero mostrarles que difícilmente una
persona puede lograr las metas solo
nosotras éramos si la punta de la lanza
pero había un montón de personas atrás
trabajando para que nosotros pudiéramos
llegar muy lejos
si nosotros mezclamos ballets y
mezclamos artes investigamos teatros y
mezclamos técnica acrobacias expresión y
trabajo en equipo lo que tenemos como
resultado es el nado sincronizado y como
es un deporte tan complejo por eso es
que nosotras necesitamos tener tantas
horas de entrenamiento en esas y en esas
horas de entrenamiento era donde nos
dábamos cuenta cuán tones es cuánto
necesitábamos de las esas capacidades
psicológicas por eso cuando ustedes vean
una rutina de nado no solamente una mía
una rutina
sincronizado de cualquier persona y
digan hay tan bonitas tan arregladitas
tan peinaditos cómo se ríen y como pasan
de bueno en la piscina tengan en cuenta
que a nosotros nos están doliendo los
músculos de una manera inimaginable que
nos está doliendo todo que seguramente
estamos teniendo muy poco oxígeno y ya
seguramente estamos viendo lucecitas y
aún así ese último poquito de fuerza que
tenemos lo estamos utilizando para
sonreír y para hacer beber al público y
hacerle ver también a los jueces que
nosotros estamos disfrutando lo que
estamos haciendo y que realmente ellos
pues ellos pueden pensar que nosotros
nos es muy fácil
como lo están viendo la vida de un
deportista de alto rendimiento no es
sólo color de rosa y menos de un
deportista que supremamente apasionado
con lo que hace
y nosotros hemos tenido muchísimas
adversidades una recuerdo una que fue el
mundial de kazán era el último antes del
preolímpico nosotras estábamos súper a
la expectativa de lo que vamos a lograr
habíamos mejorado un montón en los tres
años que habíamos trabajado estábamos
súper contenta soñando con los olímpicos
y llegamos a ese punto y nos pusieron la
misma nota de hacía tres años ya ustedes
no se imaginan la tristeza la decepción
la rabia nosotros teníamos de todo lo
malo que uno puede sentir en ese momento
y cuando nos estamos quitando la
gelatina sin sabor de la cabeza que si
es que la tiene sin sabor no es un gel
elaborado resistente al agua de gelatina
sin sabor muy espesa por esa orilla
cuando no la estamos quitando la
discusión entre este fallo giraba en
torno a cuál deporte teníamos que
pasarnos stefan me decían o bmx y yo me
miraba
no creo que tenga mucho potencial para
el bmx pero yo pensaba no entonces otro
deporte
tal vez natación carreras tiro con arco
algo en el que yo pudiera desempeñar me
sin depender de otra persona sin
depender de la posición subjetiva y de
un montón de políticas alrededor de esto
cuando uno está tan en el fondo tiene
dos opciones o se queda ya llorando o se
empuja de ahí y sale
a demostrarle al mundo y sobre todo a
demostrarle a cada uno lo que es capaz
de lograr y eso fue lo que hicimos
entrenar con unos aros olímpicos entre
ceja y ceja e ignorar a un montón de
personas que nos estaban diciendo no lo
intenten no lo van a lograr
ahora sí quiero contarles qué pasó ese 6
de marzo del 2016 cuando estamos ahí
mirando la piscina viendo en la pantalla
la rutina en cámara lenta en ese punto
en el puntico antes de que saliera la
puntuación la ansiedad a tope paula y
marga casi llorando esperando las
calificaciones y salió el ranking el
ranking era 11 y nosotros sabemos tenido
una puntuación de 79 punto 53 cuando
stefan y yo vimos ese ranking 11 esteban
me apretó inmediatamente y me apretó tan
duro y con tanta emoción que yo creo que
ya todavía no se ha dado cuenta cuánto
me dolió porque me dolió mucho pero en
ese punto con ese arañón con ese dolor
yo me di cuenta de que estaba
estirándome a recoger el fruto de un
trabajo de 21 años y un trabajo de mucha
gente que estaba alrededor de eso y que
cada cosa había valido la pena
el 10 de agosto del 2010 tomamos un
avión a río de janeiro
ajami a encontrar con los mejores
deportistas
del mundo dinará michael phelps me senté
a almorzar con rafael nadal estaba en el
apartamento con catherine ibargüen me
encontré en el ascensor con mariana
pajón me encontré con los mejores
deportistas del mundo pero hubo algo
mucho más significativo para mí y fue
salir de mi rutina y mirar a la tribuna
y encontrarme a toda mi familia
todos con camisas colombia a todos con
la bandera de colombia mi papá mi mamá
con gafas oscuras intentando disimular
que estaban llorando
y estaban todos ellos ahí
viento y ahí me di cuenta que ese
instante que estábamos viviendo fue el
fruto de un trabajo de muchas personas
pero sobre todo fue el fruto
del trabajo de mi familia porque fueron
ellos mi familia los que nunca dudaron
de lo que yo podía lograr muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]